[Music]
it's hard to probably to quantify how
important resin evil is to my generation
of developers it's not just about what
is given to the horror genre I think is
it's is one of those games it's like
doom or Tomb Raider it's a seminal game
for a generation of developers
[Music]
Pinchbeck is not alone in his views for
many developers the first resident Evo
is one of the most influential games of
all time but also stared the taste of
the generation of gamers just like me
it was a game first shown to me by my
cousins they'd let me watch bits of it
but never play it since it wasn't quite
appropriate for my young and
impressionable mind but those brief
glimpses captured my imagination and
when a school friend lay a Leonard to me
playing through Resident Evil sparked a
lifelong obsession with horror gaming in
2016 the Resident Evil franchise
celebrated its 20th anniversary and like
a lot of 20 year olds it now finds
itself in dire need of direction the
original Resident Evil define the
survival horror genre but the story of
its teenage years is one of brainless
shooters ill-conceived spin-offs
experimental episodic entries and remix
in an industry so crowded with action
games that even the most outstanding can
be lost in the shuffle Resident Evil's
place is uncertain and given the drastic
changes as genre has undergone the
series is estranged from survival horror
now more than ever
Capcom's flagship franchise now stands
at a crossroads unsure of its identity a
nun Clara's position the once great
series faces a challenge regain
relevance or risk being forgotten and
with the seventh entry Capcom is hoping
that Resident Evil can find its way
again
[Music]
across this two-part series and ahead of
Resident Evil sevens launch we'll
explore how the series became the
premiere survival horror franchise
examine how it lost his identity and
travel all the way to Japan to talk to
the developers attempting to build a new
future for it so settle in as we look at
the story of how Capcom is reviving
Resident Evil
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the 90s a decade that gave us
lots to love from fanny packs and pogs
to Tamagotchis and the Rachel but it was
also an era of technological progress
computer hardware advanced rapidly the
world wide web was invented and the
internet became commercially available
for the first time the landscape of
gaming was evolving too
developers were beginning to leave the
2d plane behind to fully embrace 3d and
the industry was shifting away from
mascot led platformers videogames were
growing up and at the center of it all
the playstation set his sights firmly on
gamers in their late teens and early
adulthood and cater towards their
maturity and no game exemplified this
more than resident evil while
pre-existing horror games such as alone
in the dark and sweet home served as its
foundation Resident Evil moved the genre
forward by pulling from classic
Hollywood horror flicks such as The
Shining and Dawn of the Dead Resident
Evil transported players into a
sprawling mansion filled with
brain-teasing puzzles and nerve-wracking
Horrors it manipulated atmosphere to
build tension and used forced
perspective to scare the player and
through all he weaved the captivating
mystery most crucially however and
removed a safety barrier of the silver
screen
placing the player not outside the
horror but at the center of it Resident
Evil codified the language of survival
horror game design and although the most
popular modern horror tale was barely
resemble Capcom's PlayStation classic
its influence and developers hasn't
diminished I don't know if the Johnny
would or wouldn't be around for Resident
Evil but I think the John Woo exists
because of Resident Evil and if he asked
anybody even if they haven't played the
early games what was the first horror
game well the horse of our game they
would say wizard and evil it might not
even be true purely historically but I
think it's kind of the granddaddy of
[ __ ]
I think what the Resident Evil titles
were really good at was they really
introduced a very different type of
stress into play that you'd have like
assumes to where you might be sort of
like counting ammo or you might be
overwhelmed at some point but it never
had that sense of real dread every
single time you cut to that door
animation and Resident Evil the sort of
bottom would fall out of your world
slightly and I'm as so many time as you
kind of you'd go in and the door would
go and you go right in you go into room
and just go no turn around a hundred
eighty degrees just walk straight back
out again you didn't want to go further
but you did want to go further than that
tension between
warnings who were not wanting to that's
where the fun really kind of lies and
the other tile recent art which does it
so well is alien isolation
you know one of the things that really
important to us with isolation was the
kind of the tension of building tension
and anticipation and I think that's
something that the original Resident
Evil did did really well that kind of
quiet moments kind of elevated the
explosive action and horror good way
that Resident Evil make people feel all
the way back at decade two decades ago
actually everybody's always asking the
developers to recapture that feeling
except that we don't live at that time
anymore
and the way we're sophisticated ball
games is very different
they understood South I said well is
that game design is about player
psychology it's not about mechanics in a
system that secondary if you don't
understand how to play it thinks and
feels then you're never gonna do your
game justice and Resident Evil got that
is the understanding that if we put one
green herb in this room that's not about
the green herb being in this room that
makes the next room scarier there's no
easy escape you can't open a door and
walk away you have to deal with the
situation that you're surrounded in and
I guess that's that's true for isolation
where you're on the sevastopol Space
Station or in the mansion in resident
evil that that there's constraints that
puts the that kind of defines some of
the pressure that the player is under
but Resident Evil's tension extended
beyond the psychological and into the
mechanical by limiting their ammunition
and health items plays had at their
disposal
it created a persistent sense of peril
and this dynamic became the cornerstone
of survival horror I think the thing
that seemed very strong was was this was
a survival game so it was about managing
your resource you couldn't play it like
another kind of action-adventure game
you couldn't be using up all your ammo
the original Resident Evil create this
amazing framework in which you had to
survive in a way that games didn't
really do at the time if they gave you
the tools it was up to you to use them
in order to make it through I think it's
a really interesting mirror in what
happened so there resin evil franchise
is what happened to say horror movies as
well the moment you put everything up
front and center it's not scary
it just isn't and Resident Evil became
as they increase the volume of bullets
and zombies it wasn't horror anymore was
action there is you know there is a
magic sweet spot where you can do
something which is phenomenally
brilliant mass-market blockbuster
entertainment I mean you know nor we dog
have cornered that completely but you
have to be really really really careful
with it and I think certainly it's what
happened you know from where I was
sitting as a as a player long before I
was a developer the Resident Evil series
of going actually this is just the
concessions to making this a an
experience which will appeal to the
broadest number of people by starting to
blur genre boundaries and I think even
with how amazing Resident Evil 4 is it
did feel like a high-water mark at the
time like actually the series wasn't
available it was gonna change from that
point yeah boy it changed Resident Evil
4 is considered the pinnacle of survival
horror introduced passier refined
gunplay and memorable set pieces but
without sacrificing the genres
delicately orchestrated tension but the
series is most critically acclaimed
entry also became the fulcrum for its
downfall
while it's populated the ride Capcom for
the move towards bombastic action the
shift was born of necessity series
creator Shinji Mikami previously said
that the greater focus on combat in
Resident Evil 4 was a response to the
commercial failure of Resident Evil
remake which signaled a decline in the
popularity of the traditional survival
horror experience a commonly held view
is that capcom only chased action in
order to appeal to a broader audience
and while this may be true the overall
shift in Resident Evil's identity was
also impacted by factors it had very
little control over perhaps the most
impactful of these was the departure of
developers that define Resident Evil
such as Shinji Mikami and Hideki Kamiya
who served vital roles in the series as
formative years and as such had the
firmest grasp on the essence of what
makes a true Resident Evil experienced
without them anchoring the series to his
roots Resident Evil started to drift and
eventually veered off course discussing
survival horror after his departure from
Capcom Mikami noted that the larger
gaming audience now valued intense
action and bombastic set pieces over
solving puzzles and running from the
undead what survival horror fans
considered fun was more niche than it
had
and to remain relevant in the global
market Resident Evil had to adapt to
meet these demands this adaptation
manifested in Resident Evil fives co-op
and Resident Evil six as three distinct
campaigns these two games are still the
most financially successful entries in
the series history but this success came
at the cost of compromising Resident
Evil's identity and many would argue
that the series has coasted along on the
strength of its name and enough star Joe
of his fan base ever since
[Music]
while Capcom fumbled with Resident Evil
Western developers supplanted the
company by leveraging survival horror
tropes to give their action games new
dimensions in many ways they were more
faithful to the spirit of Resident Evil
4 than Capcom was and followed up on it
with more success
[Music]
in America Gears of War look to Resident
Evil 4 for its over-the-shoulder
shooting and gothic stylings as Dead
Space coupled a foreboding atmosphere
with a rewarding combat system left 4
dead proved that the loss of isolation
wasn't an impediment to scaring the
player while Bioshock delivered a
thought-provoking narrative set in a
disquieting underwater sea the
decentralization of horror continued in
Europe where frictional games created
the panic inducing amnesia the Dark
Descent and helped popularize the genre
with YouTube lets players remedy played
with light and dog as a narrative theme
and a mechanical conceit in Alan Wake
and for a games as Metro 2033 was an
unrelenting ly bleak first-person
shooter set in a post nuclear ravaged
Russia Indies also rose to prominence in
the horror genre during this period with
games such as penumbra slender and five
nights at freddy's reshaping the genre
to focus on immersion puzzle solving and
delivering scares on a cerebral level
the popularity of these in turn dictated
the design of bigger budget horror
experiences and inspired games such as
outlaws soma and the aforementioned
alien isolation amongst all these both
Resident Evil 5 and Resident Evil 6
launched while respectable games in
their own right they showed that
survival horror was no longer the
primary concern for the series while the
two games remained the best-selling
Capcom titles of all time they also
backed the series into a dead end lately
it's felt like capcom has been trying to
recenter the franchise by returning to
the roots of Resident Evil Resident Evil
Revelations for example although
action-heavy focused predominantly on a
single explorable location in a way
reminiscent of the first Resident Evil
its episodic seco Revelations 2 told a
strong character-driven story had
deliberate pacing and a tense atmosphere
throughout more recently Resident Evil
remake and Resident Evil 0 were
remastered and re-released
perhaps to stoke the nostalgia of series
veterans and primed them for something
familiar the rear releases also gave
Capcom's current developers an
opportunity to better understand what
made the classic special knowledge which
could be used to inform its next project
Capcom is returning to a modernized
horror genre reshaped by Indies in
western developers by reconnecting with
his roots it firmly plants one for in
passed and now it's beginning its first
stride into an unknown future
[Music]
on the second part of this area's we
travel to Osaka home of Capcom and talk
to key Resident Evil 7 developers about
the lessons they've learned the state of
the franchise and how they're trying to
make Resident Evil relevant again